Stalin is still popular in many parts of
Eastern Europe yeah yeah and Stalin's
popular in many quarters inside
Russia uh and Stalin murdered more of
his own people than he murdered people
outside of the Soviet Union and still to
you the ties of History turn not on
individuals but on structural
considerations so so Hitler maybe a uh
surface
layer characteristics of how Germany
started War but not the really the
reason well history is a
multi-dimensional phenomenon so I hear
and we're talking about Interstate
relations here yes and realism is a
theory about how States interact with
each other and there are many other
dimensions to International politics and
if you're talking about someone like
like Adolf Hitler right uh why did he
start World War II uh is a very
different question than why did he uh
start the Holocaust or why did he push
forward a holocaust I mean that's you
know a different question and realism
doesn't answer that question so I want
to be very clear that you know I'm not
someone who argues that realism answers
every question about International
politics but it does answer what what is
you know one of the big if not the
biggest questions that IR Scholars care
about which is what causes security
competition and what causes great power
War does offensive realism answer the
question why
Hitler attack the Soviet Union Yes
because from a military strategy
perspective you know there's pros and
cons to that decision pros and cons to
every decision the question is did he
think that he could win a quick and
decisive Victory and uh he did I mean as
did his generals it's very interesting I
I've spent a lot of time studying German
decision making uh in World War II if
you look at the German decision um to
invade Poland on September 1st 1939 and
you look at the uh German decision to
invade France on May 10th 1940 and then
the Soviet Union on June 22nd
1941 what you see is there was actually
quite a bit of resistance to Hitler in
1938 at the time of Czechoslovakia
Munich and there was also quite a bit of
resistance in September
1939 internally or you mean internally
internally for sure yeah people had
doubts they didn't think the ver Mo was
ready and given the fact that world war
one had just ended about 20 years before
the thought of starting starting another
European War uh was not especially
attractive to lots of German policy
makers including military
leaders and then came France 1940 in the
runup to May 10th 1940 uh there was huge
resistance uh in the uh German Army to
attacking France uh but that was
eventually eliminated because they came
up with a clever plan uh the manstein
plan
if you look at the decision to invade
the Soviet Union on June 22nd
1941 which is the only case where they
fail they succeeded in France they
succeeded in Poland they suceeded uh at
Munich in
1938 Soviet Union is where they fail
there's hardly any resistance at all
right yeah well and to say that they
failed the Soviet Union I mean my
grandfather F I mean from from the
Soviet Union you know there's a lot of
successes early on so there's poor
military I would say uh strategic
decisions along the way but it was uh it
caught Stalin off
guard maybe you can correct me but from
my
perspective terrifyingly so they could
have been successful if certain
different decisions were made from a
military perspective yeah I I've always
had the sense they came terrifying close
to winning you can make the opposite
argument that they were doomed uh but I
I'm not terribly comfortable making that
argument I think the ver mock by the
summer of
1941 was a finely tuned instrument for
War and the Red Army was in quite
terrible shape uh Stalin had purged the
officer Corp uh they had performed po
poorly in Finland uh and uh there were
all sorts of reasons to think that they
were no match for the verock and if you
look at what happened in the initial
stages of the conflict that proved to be
the case uh the Germans won a lot of
significant tactical victories early on
and if they focused and went to Moscow
as quickly as possible it's again
terrifyingly so could have been a a
basically topple topple
Stalin um and one thing that's that's
possible that's possible fortunately
we're not going to run the experiment
again but one could argue that that had
they concentrated as the generals wanted
to do in going straight for Moscow that
they would have won I mean what Hitler
wanted to do is he he wanted to go into
the Ukraine I mean Hitler thought that
the main axis uh there were three axes
the northern axis went towards Leningrad
the central AIS of course went to Moscow
and then the southern Access Army group
South uh headed towards Ukraine and deep
into the caucuses and Hitler believed
that uh that that should have been the
main AIS and in fact in
1942 the Soviets excuse me the Germans
go back on the offensive in
1942 this is Operation Blue and the main
axis in 42 is deep into the Ukraine into
the caucuses and that fails but one
could argue that had they done that in
41 had they not gone to Moscow had they
gone you know had they concentrated on
going deep into Ukraine and into the
caucuses they could have knocked the
Soviets out that way uh I'm I'm not sure
that in the end I believe that I I think
in the end the Soviets would have won no
matter what but I'm not 100% sure of
that so sometimes um maybe you can
educate me but sometimes you know they
say just like when Napoleon winter
defeated Hitler in in Russia I think not
often enough people tell the story of
the the soldiers and the the motivation
and how hard they
fight so uh it turns out that ukrainians
and Russians are not easy to conquer
they're the kinds of people that don't
roll over and fight bravely there seems
to be a difference in certain people
peoples in how they see War how they
approach War how proud they are to fight
for their country to die for their
country these kinds of things so I think
Battle of staling gr tells at least to
me a story of extremely Brave fighting
on the Soviet side and that it's a
component of War too it's not just
structural it's not just military
strategy it's it's also the humans
involved but maybe that's a romantic
notion of war no I I think there's a
great deal of Truth in that but let's
just unpack it a bit in the case of uh
the Soviet Union in World War II the
counterargument to that um is that in
World War I the uh Russian army
disintegrated uh and uh if you look at
what happened when Napoleon invaded in
1812 and you look at what happened in
1917 and then you look at what happened
between 41 and
45 the Napoleon case looks a lot like
the Hitler case and it fits neatly with
your argument but World War I does not
fit neatly with your argument because
the Russians lost and surrendered yeah
and you the infamous Treaty of BR lovk
where the Soviet Union then because it
went from Russ Russia to the Soviet
Union in October 1917 the Soviet Union
surrendered large amounts of uh Soviet
territory because it had suffered a
humiliating defeat my argument for why
the Russians let me take that back why
the Soviets fought like wild dogs in
World War II is that they were up
against the genocidal
adversary you want to understand the the
Germans murdered huge numbers of Soviet
PS uh the overall total was 3.7 million
and by December December of 1941
remember the invasion is June 41 by
December of
1941 uh the Germans have murdered 2
million Soviet PS at that point in time
they had murdered many more PWS than
they had murdered Jews and this is not
to deny for one second that they were on
a murderous Rampage when it came to Jews
but they were also on a murderous
Rampage when it came to Soviet citizens
and Soviet soldiers right so those
Soviet soldiers quickly came to
understand that they were fighting for
their lives if they were taken prisoner
they would die so they fought like wild
dogs yeah you know the story of the
Holocaust of the 6 million Jews is often
told extensively if uh Hitler won
conquer the Soviet Union it's terrifying
to think I a much grander scam than the
Holocaust what what would have happened
to the Slavic people to the to the
Soviet people absolutely all you have to
do is read The Hunger plan right and
they also had had a plan uh what is it
called Grand planned East I forget the
exact name of it uh which made it clear
that they they were going to murder many
tens of millions of people and by the
way I believe that they would have
murdered all the Poes and all the Roma I
mean my view is that the Jews were
number one on the genocidal Hit List the
Roma or the gypsies were number two and
the Poes were number three uh and of
course I just explain to you how many PS
they had killed so they would have ended
up murdering huge numbers of uh Soviet
citizens as well but people quickly
figured out that this was happening
that's my point to you and that gave
them needless to say very powerful
incentives to fight hard uh against uh
the Germans and to make sure that they
did not
win